hello if you have found the ideas i
discussed
interesting and useful perhaps you might
consider purchasing my recently released
book beyond order 12 more rules for life
available from penguin random house in
print
or audio format you could use the links
we provide below or
buy through amazon or at your local
bookstore
this new book beyond order provides what
i hope is a productive and
interesting walk through ideas that are
both philosophically and
sometimes spiritually meaningful as well
as being
immediately implementable and practical
beyond order can be read and understood
on its own
but also builds on the concepts that i
developed in my previous books
12 rules for life and before that
maps of meaning thanks for listening
and enjoy the podcast
[Music]
hello everyone i have the pleasure today
of
speaking with bishop robert barron
we've spoken before on youtube but felt
that it was worthwhile doing so again
it's been a
long time and many people have reached
out to both of us
continually asking us to converse and so
we felt that that would be um useful
and something at least in principle of
of public interest bishop baron is the
founder of word on fire
catholic ministries and auxiliary bishop
of the archdiocese of los angeles
he's a number one amazon best-selling
author and has published
numerous books essays and articles on
theology and the spiritual life
he has been invited to speak about
religion at the headquarters of facebook
google and amazon
and is one of the most followed
catholics in the world on social media
thanks for agreeing to talk with me
again and i'm looking forward to this
conversation
yeah my pleasure jordan great to see you
too
so why do you think that
people have written to you and to me
suggesting that we converse what's your
take on this
it's surprising to me in some sense
because it's it's not really my
bailiwick you know although obviously
i've been
putting my nose in there anyways i think
for a number of reasons people see the
work you do
as at least opening a door to the
religious dimension of life for a deeper
dimension of life
i'll tell you a story i got up in front
of the bishops of the united states
because i was chairman of our
committee on evangelization and i talked
about why we're losing a lot of young
people i went through some of the
statistics and then reasons why we're
losing them
and then i gave various signs of hope
and one of the signs of hope i gave
was i called it the jordan peterson
phenomenon and what i meant was this
i told the bishops here's this gentleman
gets up
in a pretty non-histrionic way and
speaks for
several hours in some cases about the
bible
and young people all over the
english-speaking world
are listening to them in theaters and
they're by their millions on
youtube and i said you know i'm not here
to endorse everything that jordan
peterson is saying but i think
that in itself is a sign of hope
and so that became a source of some
conversation among the bishops
but i do think it's a sign of hope and i
said to them
and it's really in some ways to our
shame that you are making the bible
more compelling and appealing in many
ways than we were
so that's our that's our bailiwick
that's our profession as the bible
but you were opening the bible up in a
way that
young people especially were finding
very compelling and you were indeed i
think thereby opening a door
toward a you know a richer and fuller
understanding of the scriptures
i think that's part of it but i also
think it's the opening to
the realm of objective value so i think
as i read you and listen to you you talk
a lot about
uh the the objective realm of value
that's not simply a matter of my
subjective whim
that you know i'll decide what to do or
i make up my values as i go along
but there's something about the
tradition something about what's been
given to us
an objectivity to moral value aesthetic
value intellectual value
and see to me that's i mean it's a good
way a gateway drug to religion
because god i would say is the ground
and the source
of objective value and when you sort of
hyper-subjectivize the whole operation
that becomes you know questionable so i
think your work there too has has sort
of primed the pump
for a deeper exploration of god
as the source of these objective values
there's a couple thoughts i'd have about
it but
i remember it's almost as if we need a
third category
um subjective objective and something
else
that that is a an admixture of both i
mean
there's things i come across information
in the biological sciences particularly
that speak deeply of
an intrinsic morality
and you see this you can look at the
work of franz duvall for example who's a
dutch primatologist and he's been
studying the social interactions of
chimpanzees
and chimpanzees
share a tremendous genetic overlap with
human beings and
from an evolutionary perspective we
diverged from our common ancestor with
chimpanzees something like seven million
years ago
our cultures also share or our biology
also shares
uh properties with that of bonnabel's
but i'm going to talk about the chimps
for now
um dewalt has been interested in
what makes a chimp leader so chimps
organize their societies essentially in
patriarchal
fashion the top chimp is male
that doesn't mean there aren't high
status females there are but
the fundamental power structure appears
let's say patriarchal
and it's in the popular eye
it's easy to assume that the top chimp
is
the the the most physically intimidating
but that's actually not the case what
dewal has shown was that
is that alpha chimps who maintain
stable sovereignty let's say are
more engaged in reciprocal interactions
than
all the other chimps in the troop so
they're very
generous and reciprocal they play fair
now you can get the odd situation where
a chimp troop will be ruled by a tyrant
but
the structure becomes unstable and the
tyrant chimp tends to be overthrown by
coalitions of
other male chimps torn to pieces and so
and so then if you think well maybe
there is a pattern that constitutes this
is the
crucial issue as far as i'm concerned is
is there a pattern of behavior that
typifies stable sovereignty and i think
that's in some sense the fundamental
religious question
is there a pattern of behavior that
constitutes stable sovereignty and if so
what does it consist of
yak pancep has looked at rat behavior
and
rats juvenile male rats
engage in rough and tumble play and when
you pair them together
if one rat is 10 bigger than the other
he can dominate
the lesser rat and so they do that and
they establish their relative
dominance and then if you repeatedly
pair them together which is
a crucial issue it has to be repeated
pairings
the lesser rat has to invite the
dominant rat to play
so that's his role in the larger rat
agrees and plays
but if the larger rat doesn't let the
little rat win 30
of the time across repeated play bouts
the little rat will stop playing
and what i read that it just blew me
away it's so significant because it
shows
imagine that part of what morality is
it's
morality is precisely that pattern of
behavior
that serves to keep repeated
interactions going
and those repeated interactions might be
across days or weeks or months or years
or
decades or centuries or eons
tremendously long time span and so what
you get is
the emergence of a pattern of behavior
that's stable for the individual and
stable for society
and that as that's instantiated more and
more deeply it becomes something we can
observe and something that we adapt to
and something that then becomes part of
our central nature
and for me that's the way into the
that's the bridge between biology and
religion right there
and because there it looks like there's
an evolved ethic
that even goes beyond human beings
yeah no i wouldn't deny for a second
there's a biological ground for a lot of
this
business and i'm with lonergan the great
canadian philosopher
that the condition for the possibility
of real objectivity is a properly
constituted subjectivity so i like your
opening comment about something that
bridges the two
uh we don't just live in you know the
subjective and objective as though
they're
discreet but it's a properly constituted
subjectivity which means one free of
various prejudices one free of various
fears
one free of games of self-denial and all
that
that can properly intuit the objective
value
and objective value does indeed come up
out of the physical to some degree i
mean we're
we're embodied uh creatures so the
biological plays a role in that for sure
but i think too it goes beyond it i mean
it goes beyond simply a question of
of survival of the individual or even of
the species but certain values
you know of the truth and beauty and and
the good
that transcend that although they're
grounded in it for sure well this is one
of the things i really wanted to ask you
about because
i do think in evolutionary terms and
across
the time scale that evolutionary
biologists and physicists have
come to accept and so that's a universe
that's about 15 billion years old on a
planet that's about 4.5 billion
and with life being three and a half and
mammalian life say being 60 million
years
that's my time span the biblical time
span
is much truncated in relationship to
that
um and that's that sets up a certain
tension between
the biblical stories certainly if
they're read as
objective truth but the catholic church
from my understanding
has and this comes from the pope himself
the catholic church has already accepted
the basic tenets of evolution
but i don't know yes is that wrong
sure oh no absolutely yes okay so so but
that begs the question because
for me and i'm sure this is part of the
sticking point for young people
and maybe for people in western culture
in general is that
it's easy to say that that that
evolutionary theory has been accepted
but that still begs the question it's
right okay so fine
you can you can look at the span of life
over three and a half billion years
before you get to human beings
but our religious stories talk of a
reality that
looks like it's about fifteen 000 years
old something like that right
and so that i'm not blaming the church
for that obviously and i think the
stories in the bible are far
older than five to ten thousand years i
suspect they were part of an
extraordinarily ancient oral tradition
that stretches back tens of thousands of
years because that's the rule rather
than the exception
but and i don't know to what degree the
catholic
thinkers within the church are working
constantly to
attempt to reconcile these two
viewpoints apart from saying that they
they do accept them both yeah but i
don't think they're
i think they're apples and oranges in a
way i mean i i don't worry too much
about that issue
i'm not trying to read the bible as a
scientific text it's not about
the evolutionary process it's a
theological and spiritual text that's
discerning
truths that are i think available within
our experience
but there are discrete moments there i
mean the scientist who talks about
evolution
fine i've listened to him or her the
bible's not
concerned so much with that but it's
giving us a theological interpretation
of history and indeed of the cosmos but
not in scientific terms
so it has it has implications for our
understanding of the cosmos for sure and
of nature
of human nature but it's not done in a
scientific manner
so it just predates as you say i mean
any of what we'd associate now with the
scientific method
the last biblical text is around me are
100 a.d and so it
long predates that preoccupation so to
me it's
kind of an apple's oranges issue and
it's
i think a lot of that religion science
stuff in that sense
is an early 20th century um
preoccupation that we should just get
beyond right but i don't i i think that
may be the case but i don't think people
have gone beyond it
and i i also think that and this
pertains to
um something we also talked about
discussing which was
the continual drain from the church the
catholic church
perhaps in particular but perhaps not in
the west of young people
and i think part of that is their
inability to make intellectual sense of
of everything that they're faced with a
religious tradition and a scientific
tradition especially on the biological
front but not only that
they don't know where to place these
things in their in their
view of the world i think that's partly
why my lectures because you'd asked
about that had become popular because i
am trying to do that
and no i'll say this you look at the
surveys there's a lot of surveys now
that ask young people precisely that
question how come you left
and people speculate oh it must be
because of the scandals or because
you know they had a bad experience in
church or something number one reason
across
many years in all the surveys is i don't
believe the teachings
and then to specify that religion and
science seem to be at odds with each
other
so for young people the scientific way
of knowing is
the way of knowing so it's sort of
scientism at least implicitly
holds sway in the minds of a lot of
young people so once you make that
move knowledge equals the scientific
manner of knowing
well then the bible is non-scientific
therefore it's you know
old superstition bronze age mythology
etc
i see what you were doing jordan i think
you were doing what a lot of the church
fathers did with the scriptures because
the church fathers are very interesting
people like origen and augustine and
chrysostom and those people
they knew fully well in the third and
fourth century
that the bible should not simply be read
in a sort of
you know straightforwardly literalistic
way augustine knew that very clearly
origin do that
clearly and they talk therefore about
the different senses of scripture
what you're doing i think in a lot of
your lectures is what origen would have
called
the moral sense of the bible the
tropological the given it's kind of
technical term
the biblical texts are about the moral
life now we might say today
the psychological life or what makes you
psychologically
healthier or more productive they would
have said the moral sense
they knew all about that and so the
texts began to open up
in these marvelous ways so you know noah
and the ark
jacob and and wrestling with the angel
and the latter going up to heaven et
cetera et cetera
if you start fussing about you know the
literal
truth of these stories you're going to
miss these really deep spiritual
insights
which the church fathers knew very well
and i think you were in your own way
tapping into that
and the fact that young people were
responding to it see i think it's very
encouraging
that's why i told the bishops it's a
positive sign
that you were getting the audiences you
were getting around this well the
problem with the scientific viewpoint
technically speaking is that it's amoral
within it with within its own with it's
within its own confines by
by definition it strives not to
address issues of value now it can't
help it because scientists have to
investigate some things and not others
so value enters into it but
by its own nature science can't answer
and tries not to answer questions of
value now it gets more complicated
when you look at um work like the
primatology i discussed earlier the
origin of morality and animals and
game playing say among rats that starts
to move into the domain of morality to
some degree but
the problem with science is that it
doesn't it strips out all subjective
meaning it's designed to do that and
that leaves everyone at a loss about
what to do with the world of value and i
do believe that
um stories in particular uh
address the world of value that's their
function that's and the world of value
is the world
that that we act in it they're guides to
action
well i come across it all the time in my
work on the internet so i have
you know dialogues with people that
interact with my videos and
they'll say things like well the
sciences give us access to the truth
period the scientific method that's how
you get to the truth
and i'll say so hamlet tells you nothing
true
plato tells you nothing true
t.s eliot's poetry tells you nothing
true i mean who
who would believe that except the most
ideologically scientistic person
because he might my fear is a lot of
young people are in the grip of that
they're in the grip of a real
ideological thing they don't know how to
think their way out of it and so they
they just abandon the attempt but it
leaves them nowhere
what you were doing though is you're
showing a way out and and there there is
a way out and it's it's by you know an
introduction
into the great masters of these texts to
show you how they function
that's what a good preacher ought to be
doing you know so let let me throw
another objection then and this is
another stumbling block i think
and i think this emerges in
post-modernism in particular
um because the post-modernist there's
reasons the way for the
for their manner of thinking
so one reason is so
artificial intelligence researchers
discovered in the early 1960s that
um perceiving the landscape was much
more difficult than anybody had ever
suspected originally it was sort of felt
that
objects were just there in some simple
way and the complicated computational
problem would be
how to move among the obvious objects
but it turned out that
it's really really difficult to perceive
the environment there's an
infinite or near infinite number of ways
that you can perceive even a finite set
of objects so
um and that means there's there's a
multitude of potential interpretations
for every set of events and so that
that that was a radical discovery in the
computational world but the same
discovery basically occurred at the same
time in the world of literary analysis
for the same reason is that every text
is susceptible to a
an inordinately large number of
interpretations and it's not easy to
identify the canonical interpretation
and maybe the canonical interpretation
isn't canonical it just serves
power for example and that would be you
know religion as the opiate of the
masses or
or religion as a political tool and i
think that takes
things far too far but there's a real
problem here is that
if you divorce the narrative from the
objective world
and say well the narrative is valuable
because it gives us a guide to value
then you have another problem is which
in instantly which is
okay which narrative and how do we make
a hierarchy of value
among narratives we would say hamlet is
deeper than
um harlequin romance right
but trying to specify why that is and
what
deep means is very very difficult and
you might say well the bible is the
deepest of all narratives but
that still begs the question well
compared to buddhist
writings say compared to the upanishads
or compared to any long-term complex
mythology that's developed
over thousands and thousands of years
what makes it canonical why is it
preferable to shakespeare for example
and so
well so perhaps i could get you to
address that because that's a
vicious problem there's a lot there and
i'll start with your opening remark by
post-modernism because i quite agree
with you
i'm not simply anti-post-modern in fact
i wrote a book called
toward a post-liberal catholicism where
i took in a lot of the insights of the
postmoderns
one of which is as you quite correctly
say a sort of legitimate perspectivalism
that we never
get reality you know too cool right just
open my eyes there's reality
again that's liner again it's only a
properly constituted subjectivity that
that opens the door to the properly
objective
but one of those ways of properly
constantly your subjectivity
is to put your subjectivity within a
community of discourse
so it's never the case that i simply
intuit the way things are
and end of the argument no it's as
lonergan said it's not the kojito that
was the trouble with the
enlightenment it's the kojitamos it's
always we think
and that means i have my perspective i
bounce it off your perspective you
bounce off somebody else's
we have a disciplined and structured
conversation
and in that process all the different
aspects of the real begin to emerge
or like my intellectual hero john henry
newman
said the contents of a real idea is
equivalent to the sum
total of its possible aspects that's
about 1870 says that
which is really an extraordinary thing
because he anticipates in many ways the
phenomenologists
you know when they talk about uh walking
around an object and to intuit its
essence thereby
and the walking around is not just i
walk around but you're walking around
and someone else is walking around
we're all exchanging our points of view
and again i'd bring this into line with
catholicism which is always stress the
communitarian element
that we know precisely in the community
of the church
now link to the bible the bible's never
like just open it up
you're a single subjective uh
viewer and now you take in its meaning
well no we've always said the bible is
read within the church
in this long interpretive tradition
where i'm bouncing it off of augustine's
perspective we've got it from origen
who now throws it to thomas aquinas who
now brings it to newman
and then through preachers and teachers
through the saints
so you've got the technical intellectual
interpretation of the bible then you
have the saints
who in many ways they embody the bible
so i'm going to read
a lot of the biblical stories in light
of friends of assisi in light of
teresa of calcutta et cetera so i like
that side if you want of the post-modern
which is much more attuned to the
communal way in which we come to know
things um
the big question you raised at the end
we could spend some time with that
how do you make ultimate judgments and
determinations like
this one is right you know well you you
hinted at it a bit there by saying well
look
many many people have looked worked on
this for a very very long period of time
and in some sense it's a living document
right because right because it does have
to be the bible just doesn't exist as a
book on a shelf
it's it's a pattern of meaning within a
context and the context has to be taken
into account
um so you say well there's a powerful
context for its interpretation
it's also a fundamental text in that
the bible is implicit in all sorts of
other great texts
like shakespeare or any anything that's
a product of
judeo-christian culture that's a deep
product is deeply affected by the bible
so it's there
implicitly whether you like it or not
and so it has to be taken seriously
i would say even if you don't believe it
but then to the degree that you believe
the central axioms of western culture
you have to wonder how much of
what's biblical you do end up believing
because of its implicitness
well yeah i mean it's all through the
western culture for sure um
and the question of belief you know in
some ways is the most fundamental
question in all of theology
we call it fundamental theology how do
you how do you articulate the meaning of
belief
and you know for the best people in our
tradition belief is always on the far
side
of reason not the near side of reason
and that's a mistake that so many people
make today
young people especially faith or belief
they
mistake for credulity or superstition
something
sub-rational and our best people of
course have always repudiated that
authentic faith is on the far side of
reason so reason's done all the work it
can
and should do but then there's this
moment when
the claim is made deus dicks it right
that god
has spoken now do i believe that or not
i think it's precisely analogous to
coming to know a person
you know so i know something about you
just from watching you over the years
and i can google you and i can read your
books and i can
come to some sort of objective knowledge
of you
uh now in this virtual means i've you
know met you
and so my mind is working trying to
understand where you're coming from
but let's i mean project into the future
if you and i uh
met in person you and i eventually
became friends
and at some point you spoke a truth
about yourself that i could never have
gotten on my own i could never have
gotten it from
any objective source you revealed
something to me
right of your inner life and at that
point i've got to make a decision
well do i believe that or not i can't
prove it i can't
ratify it it's congruent with everything
i've known so that's one test i could
give
if you told me something that's just
wildly incongruous with everything else
i know about you
i'd probably not believe that but if you
tell me something that's congruent with
what i know
but goes beyond it and i have to say at
that point
okay i i have to believe that or not
i think faith is like that in a way so
the bible
i can approach into all kinds of
different ways but the claim being made
at the heart of the bible
of biblical revelation is deus dixit
god has spoken god has said something in
this text
do i accept it and and that has to be a
decision
that's born of something beyond reason
not opposed to it but beyond it
so that's i think where belief in the in
the religious sense comes in
so um i have
i understand that argument but i have
trouble with it i would say
um so we could talk about faith a little
bit
um and this is groping around in the
darkness
um it seems to me that gratitude is a
form of faith
it's a deci it's like a decision in some
sense
because you could look at the world and
you could say well there's
plenty of reasons to be grateful and
there's plenty of reasons not to be
and so the evidence doesn't necessarily
support one interpretation or another
but a decision about whether or not to
be grateful
is going to affect the way i interpret
the world and also perhaps the way it
reveals itself to me
and the way i act in it and the
consequences of my action
so i would say it seems to me to take
faith to be grateful and
that seems to be a worthwhile faith um
it seems to me to take faith to operate
always when we don't know what we're
doing and we usually don't know what
we're doing
and so part of the reason that you have
to have faith is because you're actually
ignorant
and it fills in the gaps right because
otherwise you'd be stuck with a
never-ending regress
you just ask why all the time and then
you could never act because the y
has to end somewhere and i think by
virtually by definition it ends with an
act of faith that might be akin to your
idea about faith being beyond reason
it's like well look if if i ask you why
you're
having this conversation with me you'll
give me a reason
and if i ask you why that reason is
valid you'll give me another reason and
if i do that five or six times
you're going to run out of reasons and
but you're still having the conversation
so that means you have faith that the
conversation can go somewhere good and
that's not actually a delusion
no no and actually you're moving toward
god and i think that's a classic
route in our tradition um and just the
way you were doing it
why are we having this conversation i
give you know these particular reasons
but then
ask the why again ask it a third or
fourth or fifth time
finally i'm going to get to something
like well because i want to be happy
you know what ultimately motivates the
will
is some desire for happiness what's
happiness
well keep pressing that question it
can't be something simply
in this world we all know that doesn't
make us happy in the way that we're
seeking
it's something like the sumumbonum right
somewhat the ultimate good
i want to be happy in the fullest
possible sense all the time
which is why you know taylor de chardin
said this that i wouldn't get out of bed
in the morning unless i believed in god
and that's what he meant was if you do
that kind of horizon analysis
of every act of the will even the
simplest like getting out of bed you
finally come to the sumo bonum okay so
let me walk through that
okay let me walk through that because i
think that that's a useful thing to
think about
technically i've thought about identity
in this regard because identity is a
nested structure
yeah it's also a lens through which we
view the world
and so if i'm sitting at my typewriter
typing
you might ask me what i'm doing and the
answer is well i'm moving my fingers up
and down yeah
but then that's true and the next answer
is well i'm
i'm producing words on a page
but i'm also producing phrases and i'm
producing sentences and i'm producing
paragraphs and then
chapters and then a book and then you
might say well
are you writing a book or are you being
a professor and i'd say no well i'm i'm
being a professor
pushing my fingers up and down on this
keypad and then you might say well
what is what's professor nested in and
the answer to that would be something
like well
good citizen and then that's nested in
good man
and then that's nested in well then
that's right where you start to
encounter
what i think are something like
religious presuppositions it's like
right
well what exactly do you mean by good
man and i think
i think psychologically i think well
that means to act out the
mythological hero and that's exactly the
point where that identity
touches on something that's i think
indistinguishable from religion at that
end now i'm not sure what that means
about god
per se i would say this that god
in our great tradition could be defined
as the good in its unconditioned form
so all the things you've been you've
been raising here so the yyy
i'm answering with some kind of good
with a conditioned good
the very fact that i can put it in a
wider context means it's conditioned
it's good i'm seeking it but it's not
the ultimate thing i'm seeking
so unless we have an infinite regress
which i think is repugnant to reason
and immobilizing you know there are
people who have neurological conditions
that put them into an infinite regress
and they cannot act right so if that's
repugnant both let's say
epistemically and psychologically we
have to come to something
that's properly called the unconditioned
good good in its
absolute form that which is is desirable
simply for its own sake so aquinas will
say god is called good because god is
the supremely desirable
what do we desire thomas says some form
of actuality or being
that's why we call god the fully real
that which is
most most uh actual octaspuros
right but i like the analysis it comes
not so much cosmologically but
psychologically
from what motivates me and finally
unless my life just sort of
uh founders into irrationality i am
motivated
by ultimately oh my god right well i i
think so
because you know me i would also say
well let's
let's let's reject that argument and say
well you're
you're not nested in good man good
citizen
hero and then beyond that you know
cosmic hero
and i think psychologically speaking the
figure of christ is if nothing else a
cosmic hero
and and i'm not saying it it's nothing
else but it's
it's at least that well what would the
alternative be well you wouldn't be
doing what was good well then what's on
the outskirts of your
value structure is something that's
adversarial something that's
the opposite of good and maybe maybe
you're
likely in fact your psyche is not pure
and you
you know you you you vary
depending on your faith i suppose
but but but there's no
escaping being nested in some sort of
transcendent structure like that and
then
i think of it this way so you have this
outermost reach of your identity
structure which is something like
whatever the idea of good man is
grounded in
and i do think it's grounded in this
hero narrative but then i look at the
hero narrative and i think
well that's a biologically uh that's an
emergent
narrative it has evolutionary roots it's
something like
man has discovered that his goal is to
move into the unknown to confront what's
what's predatory and and dangerous and
to garner something of great value
in return and to share it with the
community and it's an ancient ancient
story
it echoes through the old testament
continually
um it's even there it's even there it
lurks underneath the accounts of god's
creation
itself and and and that that means that
that outermost
rim of identity is something that has an
evolutionary origin
and then you think well that means that
it has to be connected
it's connected with reality in some
fundamental sense
does that demonstrate the existence of
god
that's a well that's a different
question but but you can push you can
you can make a logical case for the
necessity of that
that hypothesis of goodness to that
point as far as i can tell
stay with first with your example of of
someone let's say it was really wicked
and there are wicked people you know we
can analyze that psychologically or two
of them are sitting right here well yeah
i mean because it goes right through the
human heart
uh as soon as said um but
thomas aquinas says a wicked person even
the most wicked person
is seeking at least the apparent good so
some
something that appears good to that
person now they could be totally
mixed up about it it's not in fact good
for them but at least it appears good to
them
so even the most wicked person thomas
says is
incoherently seeking god because it's
always some good
and now he's got the wrong sense of it
but he's still being drawn and motivated
by this first cause of the will
even the most wicked person see but i
think that's a sign of hope
that means grace is always possible now
read whether it's dolcevsky or flannery
o'connor and
people that talk about the most wicked
types
but they're sometimes the place where
grace breaks through
you know because they are seeking god in
their in their perverse way
so in a way he's got us coming or going
you know i mean whether we're mother
teresa or we're
a a wicked dostoevsky character
we're all seeking god in some way and i
agree with you about the bible the bible
well i see i'm i'm not that optimistic
because i
i think that i think i don't think that
all evil actions are misguided um
i think that because and i think that's
best illustrated in the story of cain
and abel
and ike took the story of kane extremely
seriously
i think it has unbelievable explanatory
power it's quite staggering that the
power of that story
the explanatory power especially for how
short it is
you know cain is resentful he has his
reasons his sacrifices were
repudiated by god for reasons that
aren't made clear in the text which is a
great ambiguity
because often our sacrifices are
repudiated and cain is bitter and no
wonder and he has able around to rub his
nose in it as well but kane's reaction
is
i'm going to destroy what god values
most
and that now you might say well kane is
conflicted and ambivalent about that and
i believe that but
yeah but i don't think he was seeking
the good when he killed when he struck
down
he was he was he was shaking his fist at
god yeah
indeed he was objectively but he was
seeking at least the apparent good for
him
in his twisted mind he thought that was
the good i don't believe it
i don't believe it i think you can get
to a point where you're
so resentful i really believe this that
you're so resentful that you will do
harm to yourself
as well as everyone else and actually
truly but a suicide is seeking at least
the apparent good
a suicidal person thinks my
non-existence is a good thing
so they are seeking the good but in a in
a twisted misguided way
um and it's to me it's got metaphysical
roots because i would hold to the
classical view that that
evil is a provazzio bony right it's a
privation of the good so good is always
more fundamental than evil it has to be
they're not they're not co-equal
principles fighting away
so i i'd repudiate any sort of gnostic
or manichaean
system that metaphysically too i believe
that i thought about that a lot
jung is being accused of manichaeanism
for example because he took evil so
seriously
who he has sorry i couldn't carl you yes
yes
but but but you know he took evil
extraordinarily seriously which is
something that's definitely worth doing
so look you look at examples like the
columbine killers
yeah well you know you could have
the suicide could have come before the
murders
but it didn't and so
i don't i even see maybe in those
situations the desire for non-existence
not so much as a seeking of the good but
a desire to punish
god for the inadequacy of his creation
yeah oh no it could be but but at least
in their mind that's a good thing
so that's the cain connection that the
resentment against god and getting back
at god
sure i see it in the pastor life all the
time it's a justified thing they think
for them it is god deserves it
because look at what's happened but see
but god has his coming or going because
that
that is in fact a quest for god
that's right i mean even even the most
uh resistant sinner
is in fact under grace in that sense
that's why i've always liked both origen
and c.s lewis say this that
it's the love of god that lights up the
fires of hell right if someone's in hell
it's it's the resistance to god's love
that's lighting up the fires it's
causing the friction
and so god has you coming or going i
mean is god present in hell
sure because whatever is has to be
grounded in god
and god's even present in the fires of
hell because
it's the resistance against god that's
causing them you know
so i i think uh it's a metaphysical
statement and a psychological statement
about the primacy of the good but it's a
source of hope and a lot of my pastoral
work you know and
you as a psychologist too when you go
into people's pain
in a very deep way and priests go all
the time to these limit situations where
people have
lost loved ones they're facing their own
death they're facing tremendous
failure that's where priests go
you know because that's often where
where grace is going to break through
well there are i've encountered
situations as a clinician
yeah where where religious language is
the only language
that can be used to describe what's
happening that's quite interesting it's
difficult to relay those experiences
outside the specific framework of the
occurrences
yeah i always think of you know hegel
said to noah limit as a limit is to be
beyond the limit
and i think that's that's true here so
whether it's the physical sciences or
psychology
our reason comes to a certain limit but
then it recognizes the limit as a limit
and that's to be already beyond it in a
way and they often talk about religious
questions as limit questions or it's a
limit situation
when i begin to ask the meta question
beyond questions
or i come to a meta experience beyond
any ordinary experience
and that's why again priests tend to
show up at those limit
cases that's when we're looking into
this
abyss and it is from our standpoint
rather abyssal i mean
what is it that stands beyond what i can
know and control
and there's this i mean do a kierkega
guardian there's a kind of
leap that that abyss is something um
loving and what stands beyond what i can
control
is a force of love that's actually
summoning me
and that's where i go back to what i
said about deus dixa god
speaking through the scriptures i think
that's what it means the voice from the
cloud is a symbol of it you know
um when someone hears the voice of god
it's
coming from the abyss it always is job
you know the voice comes out of the
whirlwind
so your your eyes are closed and you
know you can't see anything but from the
whirlwind comes the voice
because and again that speech is so
important because
joe where were you when i did all these
i mean what do you know about what's
going on you know nothing about what's
going on
but from the abyss beyond reason comes
the voice
and the bible witnesses to that stuff
all the time
and boy it happens in people's
experience i mean you and i both know
that when you
you come up against limits what comes
out of the abyss
is a very interesting thing well one of
the ways that's interesting to think
about this i think is that
well let's assume that at the outermost
limits of your identity
you don't make the assumption that
you're
involved in an enterprise that's good
nested inside a being that's good let's
say you take the opposite
approach to that what happens to your
behavior and
what i believe i've observed and i tried
to document this particularly in my book
maps of meaning is that
you start acting in ways that make
everything worse
very rapidly yes so and that
and so for i had a debate a while back
with a with an anti-natalist david
benatar
and he believes that existence is so
rife with suffering conscious existence
is so rife with suffering
that it would be better if it just
didn't exist at all
so and dostoevsky's ivan makes that case
in
the brothers karamazov brilliantly
brilliantly he tortures his
brother eliosha who's the novitiate um
and it's a very interesting book because
eliot is nowhere near the
returration that ivan is but he is the
most admirable
character in the book because of the
totality of his personality not because
of the brilliance of his rational mind
it's an amazing book in in that regard
but the problem i had with benatar's
hypothesis wasn't
it's its axiom because i think you can
you can make a strong case that there's
so much suffering in the world that
um the question of its validity is a
valid question
the problem for me there is that if you
do that and you start to act that out
um things take up things appear to take
a vicious turn very rapidly you start
working against
everything that's alive and striving yes
and
no quite right um gosh there's a lot
there i was thinking of as you were
talking
the uh dante's image of satan at the pit
of hell
not in a fiery place but an icy place
much much better symbol of stuck
surrounded by the betrayers yeah to
chewing on the three great
traitors but his great wings he's meant
to fly he's meant to fly up into the
into the presence of god
but all they do is he's beating his
wings and that's our earlier point about
he's seeking god i mean satan is seeking
god you have to
that's the way the will functions but
all he's managing to do
is make the world around him colder so
as he's beating his wings he's just
he's creating the meteorology of hell
you know so that's what happens when
someone gets really
stuck they are in fact seeking god
but they and he cries from all six eyes
he's got six eyes and he's
weeping and he's drooling from the
people he's chewing
and he's stuck and he's making the world
colder it's a beautiful picture
of what happens it's really useful too
for for listeners to realize you look if
you look at
this is my opinion and you can take it
for what it's worth
um the images of satan
in paradise lost and in dante's inferno
are unbelievably
instructive if you all if you start to
understand that what these thinkers were
trying to do was to
produce an imaginative representation of
evil
and evil as an embodied and transcendent
um
being and uh and the the psychological
rationale for that i believe
and it has something to do with our
ability to communicate which you
referred to earlier is that
the evil we do is informed by the entire
human race's
conception of what constitutes evil
and and and stretching back from the
beginning of
the time when we began to communicate so
for example
you you see this quite clearly i read
the columbine killer's
notes in quite a bit of detail and it's
saturated with
satanic thought and the reason for that
is that
that sort of thought is part of the
culture because
we've come to represent these
transcendent figures of evil in poetry
and in movies and
it happens all the time in movies with
characters say like hannibal lecter and
in horror movies and um um
the the the milton's
satan who's often viewed at least by
some as a revolutionary
hero seems to me to be something like
the rational mind
it's what happens to the rational mind
when it places its presuppositions in
the place of god that
because satan seems to
presume that he can replace the
transcendent
by his own presuppositions and i think
that's
my reading of that is that's actually
what happened on earth
not long after milton wrote when these
totalitarian states emerged
it's something solzhenitsyn commented on
and where the presuppositions the
utopian presuppositions of man
rationally thought out were seen as
sufficient to
to represent everything the totality to
eliminate the need for something
transcendent
and the consequence of that was that
they produced something that looked an
awful lot like hell
hell and dante did that more
psychologically and so
milton milton being the great poetic
genius that he was
had a poetic sense that that was what
was coming down the pipelines
do you i wonder if you read your
countrymen uh charles taylor much the
the canadian
philosopher because catholic too
taylor said that we in the west let's
say western europe america canada
australia we might be the first
civilization
ever ever to think you can find real
happiness
apart from a transcendent reference
point and
everyone in human history has felt
something like
the alluring darkness beyond what i can
control and know
is necessary a relationship to that
realm
is necessary for happiness we're the
first culture ever
that said no i don't care i'm
indifferent to it
but that does produce versions of hell
for sure because
something will take the place of of the
transcendent
point of reference well it seems useful
even even from the perspective of
humility i mean i don't know if this is
a reasonable thing to say
but a tyrant who believes in god is
likely preferable to one who doesn't
because at least in principle
tyrant is held accountable by something
that isn't him
that's right he even and and he would
get caught at least
in principle again in the operation of
his own conscience
don't you i i love the fact in the
scriptures they're very unique this way
they do not apotheosize their leaders
and it's very different from so many
other ancient cultures where the
kings become like gods and there's the
bible i mean the bible is
bluntly honest about its leaders and his
kings
even the greatest even david murderer
adulterer
solomon saul the whole realm of them
that's a brilliant insight of the bible
that all these people are
under god and they're under judgment
and that's a that's a liberating idea
and when we lose that the leaders do
become apotheosized well you saw that in
rome constantly in ancient rome that
literally happened
you know and there's always a proclivity
for that to happen that's the imperial
presidency you know
right and i think it's very important i
always tell when i when i'm preaching on
this subject to
christians the fact that jesus is called
the son of god it was so important
because it was dethroning the roman
claim that the emperor
was the austro you know so one of the
titles after julius caesar
is is divas he's he's divinized then his
son
augustus becomes the son of the god you
know
so when the the first evangelists were
saying i've got good news
about jesus the son of god they were
saying
right it's not caesar he is not the son
of god
this one whom caesar killed by the way
he's the son of god
but the bible's always making that move
of knocking our own pretensions off
their their pedestals
i think that's an amazing observation
actually and
it is one of the things that that that
is extraordinarily striking about the
old testament
is that it's so sophisticated
psychologically because
what's happening there is that the idea
of
absolute sovereignty is disconnected
from the person bearing the sovereignty
and so at the very least again speaking
psychologically what you have is
um the representation of god as
that which is sovereign and now each
individual can be a representative of
that
and can have that operate within them
but they aren't that and
that that that well as i said at the
least that's a
brilliant psychological innovation and
the fact that the biblical
characters are so they're realistic to
the point of
dostoevsky and painfulness you know
abraham doesn't leave home till he's
what
80. he's 75.75 he's a slow he's a late
starter right
and and then his life is just one
god-awful catastrophe after another for
the first while it's like
you know you have some contempt for him
let's say because he's hanging around
his father's tent
and then he does finally pay attention
to the call of adventure to god's voice
and he goes out and encounters tyranny
and starvation and corruption and
yeah and he makes all sorts of mistakes
and you know
and it's easy to be contemptuous i think
of the biblical characters
because of that but it actually speaks
to their intense psychological realism
and it's so useful for for people to see
that because
abraham for example is blessed by god
despite the fact
despite despite his evident character
flaws and that's the case for
for for the patriarchs in general and
it is remarkable right a descent of
yours i'll put in the throne that will
last forever to david who was a deeply
flawed character
what i find cool is that even before you
get to the human
characters go to the very beginning of
the bible and you have a dethroning
of the cosmic pretenders to the absolute
so in the creation account
you know sun moon stars planet animals
the earth itself
all the things mentioned were worshiped
in different contexts so
the author is saying no no no no they're
not divine they're
creatures but then he turns it around
beautifully but they have a purpose
which is to give praise to god so
they're not god
they should be dethroned from that but
now they're given the privilege of
praising god with their manner of being
led by the conscious creature
human beings who and catholics know this
whoever comes at the end of a liturgical
procession
is the one that leads the prayer so
genesis the opening verses sound like a
liturgical procession you know
the first is then that evening came
morning follow then the fourth day and
it's like a steady procession of
liturgical
actors the last figure the human being
is the one now
that will lead the chorus of praise to
my mind it's the master theme of the
whole bible if you want
is we're rightly constituted when we
give praise to god and can lead all of
our creaturely brothers and sisters
in the right praise of god sin is bad
praise
from it's without fail in the bible it's
they went after false gods they went
after the gods of those people they
they abandoned the teaching of the lord
bad praise
leads to the disintegration of the self
so that's now in the psychological order
that's really well praises praises what
what you praise is what you pursue
and so if you're pursuing the wrong
thing then you're going to fall apart
right one of the great biblical ideas i
think is you become what you praise so
what gets your worth ship that's the
origin of our word there what what's the
highest worth for you
you become that you know so you become
what you worship
you're meant to become children of god
but what happens we end up worshiping
something so every one of us worships
something and we become
conformed to that and then if it's not
god
we disintegrate and then like satan we
start beating our wings and making the
world around us worse
so that the world around us
disintegrates that's the bible the bible
tells that story over and over and over
again
you know which is why you know from a
catholic perspective a christian
perspective
that jesus on the cross is offering the
father
right praise on our behalf and see now
you're getting to the mass
which is very powerful you know that the
mass
is the great act of praise where we
join ourselves to the sacrifice of the
son we say
we we conform ourselves to christ i have
to ask you about that because it's just
burning a hole in me well i'm in chronic
pain
a lot of it and it's constant
and i'm not i don't know what to do with
it
generally speaking i know things that
make it worse
you said something a lot of ideas were
flashing through my mind
and i want to i want to hit at it
because it's a crucial concern
you said something so surprising that
christ on the cross was
offering up the proper praise to god
it's like well i'm not going to just let
you say that without
noticing it because that's a hell of a
thing to say so i'm going to put
together some things that you
touched on and and then we can address
this so
you said in the bible one of the things
that's remarkable about it is the
conception of the divine
so the conception of what is of highest
worth
is stripped from some of its obvious
objects of
projection the sun the moon the cosmos
the stars
um but then also earthly leaders of
other cultures idols and also
earthly leaders of your own culture says
no whatever the ultimate divine is
it's not to be found in its fullest
expression in any of those examples it's
something
else okay so then the question is well
what is that
else well the christian answer is well
whatever it is
for in its human form let's say it's
something human
it's something that humans can aspire to
it's both of those
and and and it's made manifest in the
figure of christ
something specifically human but then
you have this terrible paradox
with christ which is partly the paradox
that you just laid out which is
a very difficult thing to get a grip on
so what is it exact why is what christ
is doing
proper sacrifice is it because it is
what is it his willingness to bear the
pain
what is it yeah that's close to it
so we say the word became flesh so the
word
who is always in the presence of the
father so the word doesn't worship the
father because the word is god
so we shouldn't talk about worship
within the trinity itself
but now the word becomes flesh because
the father
god so loved the world he sent his only
son that all who believe in him might
have eternal life in his name
he sends the son into flesh but
into flesh that's been so compromised by
sin
so not into a pristine creation
now what do you have that's an
interesting question theologically what
do you have sent the sun
if creation had not fallen that's an
interesting question right in fact
it did the valuable fall that laid the
yeah the
cool part right yes it's a remarkable
idea
it is indeed but like don scotus argued
you know the franciscan
medieval theologian that god would have
sent his son even if we hadn't sent but
that's another question okay so let's
take that apart for just a sec so that
people are clear about it so the theory
here is that
there is something wrong with the
structure of creation that that's its
steepness and sin and
everyone has to ask if they believe that
and and it seems to me that people do is
there's a sense that things
aren't how they should be that we're not
how we could be that something
has gone astray and is continuing to go
astray which is a mystery in and of
itself if it's a god-created world
it's like well why is that precisely
well i mean the quick answer is is
corrupted freedom you know or
a misguided freedom you might say but
the word comes into flesh into fallen
flesh
and the cross is what the cross is
cruelty and hatred and violence and
institutional injustice and stupidity
and if you read the passion narratives
it's it's a beautiful sort of poetic
presentation of all that's wrong with us
that comes out to meet him and bearing
all of that he continues in his
relationship
of of obedience and unity with the
father
so bearing the sins of the world
bearing all the dysfunction and twisted
quality of the world
he brings us back online
so in in the attitude of the word made
flesh on the cross
we see a sinful corrupt hate-filled
world
now brought painfully back online
that's the sacrifice of the cross that's
pleasing to the father
so we should never play the game of well
the father is like a is a
dysfunctional alcoholic father that you
know is now demanding
this blood sacrifice it's it's rather
the father is
pleased by the son's entry into our
fallen situation and his bearing
of all that dysfunction even as he
brings
us back online to the father okay so why
does
okay so let's say christ maintains
his i know this isn't exactly the right
way of thinking about it but it'll
work for rhetorical purposes i think
it's
so christ is tortured by betrayal
by by by physically and
spiritually as well because the best way
to torment someone
is when is to punish them despite their
innocence right
yeah so right right or maybe worse than
that
to punish them because of their virtues
that's even
better and so that's that's intrinsic in
this story as well
christ bears up under that he doesn't
repudiate
god or doesn't repudiate his own essence
it's something like that
he but then what is the is the
example of that is the example of
bearing up under that
exceptional duress and maintaining a
moral stance is that the example that
redeems the world is it that
if you do that in your own life the
world is de facto redeemed
it is that but more because if it's just
that then a pelagian system would be
true that we just need a good you know
moral
exemplar it's something more than it's
just merely good i mean it's super human
what's being asked for
no true but it is something more
metaphysical about it
it's a reworking of the way things are
if if jesus takes upon himself
all the dysfunction of the world and
swallows it up
in the ever greater divine mercy so
it's it's christ bearing all of our
dysfunction but transfiguring it
in his great act of of forgiveness and
obedience to the father that i think all
of that coming together
simultaneously is the sacrifice that's
pleasing to the father
in some ways the word from the cross
father forgive them
they know not what they do is that is
the most important
or or play with this to jordan that
after the resurrection so jesus comes
back
precisely to those who had denied him
and betrayed him and
and run from him in his moment of
greatest need and in almost any
telling of a similar story if that all
happened and then the person who had
died is back from the dead
and he appears to those who had
abandoned him you'd expect him to you
know wreak havoc on them right
so jesus shows his wounds to be sure
because
the wounds of jesus are a sign of the
world's dysfunction
if i'm ever tempted you know when we
were younger the book um
i'm okay your okay came out right so
we're always tempted to say well you
know basically we're okay just need a
little fixing up around the edges
whenever we're tempted to say that it's
the wounds of jesus that say otherwise
that's why i was insisting earlier that
i don't you know that that it isn't
merely misguided good that
turns people towards the darkness it's
it's it's
voluntary desire to produce the darkness
as well
anyways i do take that very seriously
and it's an interesting idea is that the
ideal is wounded in proportion to the
degree that everything has deteriorated
away from the ideal
and that's almost by definition true
right yeah yeah no that's true but
it's just the if the very act of the
will itself is structured in such a way
it has to be seeking
some kind of at least apparent good but
that's our earlier
issue um so the wounds
show the dysfunction of the world which
the son of god took upon himself but
then
then the word of shalom which is in all
the resurrection accounts that jesus
says
peace so when
when paul for example says i'm certain
that neither death nor life
nor angels or principalities nor
heighten or death nor any other creature
could ever separate us from the love of
god
how does he know that because we killed
and he returned with the word of
forgiveness
so so that means it's like it's it's
like for the
divine goodness and forgiveness can
trump any evil
even the evil of killing god so
we killed him but yet he returned in
forgiving love
i think that's the moment when
christianity is born
in the dual sense of yes we kill them
look at the wounds
but he says shalom to us nevertheless so
that
i i can't run away from him i can try
you know that's what all the sinners do
i can try but ultimately the divine love
is such that it's it's
greater that's why paul can all say
we're sin abounds
grace abounds the more that's
christianity so
the greatest sin we kill the son of god
there's no greater sin than that
where sin abounds grace abounds the more
and see
all of that was made possible in a way
by the great sacrifice of the cross
which is why it's a saving act
um now that's i'm i'm striving to
understand person okay so i want to ask
you
a bunch of questions about that so we
talked a little bit before about the
church bleeding
its people they're leaving the young
people are leaving and my sense of that
is it's because
the church does not demand enough of its
of of the young of young people yeah i
think it doesn't demand enough and
by not demanding enough it doesn't
indicate its
faith in their possibility and yeah
so now in orthodox christianity as i
understand it
there seems to me to be more emphasis on
the idea that
it's each human's obligation to become
like christ that's the goal well that's
that's that by definition we could say
and we could speak psychologically about
this as well
that means to become the ideal the ideal
that's beyond rationality even that's
what you're aiming at
that's what's hypothetically within your
grasp
for and it seems to me as well that
that's what the mass
symbolizes is that and i'd be happy to
have
any objections to this i would be happy
to hear
the the incorporation of the host is the
is the embodiment it's the incarnation
of christ within that's what it's
acting out that's the idea i mean in
some sense it's
it's the consumption of the saving
element but the saving element is
actually a mode of being
and this isn't hit home it's like look
what the
church the church demands everything of
you
yeah absolutely everything and then the
reason that that
people are leaving is because that
adventure isn't being put before them
it's like look you can have your cars
and your money and all of that but
that's nothing compared to the adventure
that you could be going on
yes i i wish you'd preach to our people
because
i think you're absolutely right about
that uh the language we'd use
is um be a saint that's what that's the
ordinary goal of every baptized person
is to be a saint
a saint means someone who's holy or
utterly conformed to christ
now press that to be conformed to christ
means
you're willing to go into the
dysfunction of the world
to bear its pain and to bear to it
the ever greater divine mercy and love
now fill in the blank
francis of assisi mother teresa may be
in our time like when we were
younger if someone said well who's a
living saint we all would have said
mother teresa
well what did she do she went into the
worst slum in the world i'd been there
and she bore the suffering of of of the
world
literally picking up the dying and and
bearing their
disease and bearing their psychological
suffering and and she she took on
herself
the wounds of jesus but then think about
you know the smile of mother teresa she
brought to that place
the ever greater more super abundant
mercy of christ
that's being a saint and you're dead
right i think we're not sufficiently
calling our people to that okay i can
tell you one thing i've experienced
and this is this is really something to
see i spoke in about 150 cities
sequentially with a day or two
in between and to large audiences three
to
ten thousand all the time something like
that and
i always paid attention to the audience
singly because i was always talking to
one person at a time but also
on mass you know to see to hear
because if if the words are in landing
in the right place and hypothetically
emanating from the proper source
then there's silence and
sometimes that silence can be dramatic
and that's why people say well you could
have heard a pin drop it's no one's
moving because their attention
is 100 percent gripped by whatever just
happened
and one thing that reliably elicited
that was
the proposition that the meaning that
sustains you
and protects you from corruption during
suffering
is to be found in responsibility
and people that and i thought i thought
part of the reason that that produced
silence was because
no one says that now they say happiness
or they say rights or they say
privileges or
or or they say reward or something like
that they don't say
pick up the heaviest load you can care
and carry
and care for that matter and stumble
forward
and i've seen people cut those ideas and
put them on t-shirts and
and play with them and and so
it's not that the church is asking too
little of its people
no i i it is asking too little of them i
i quite agree
it's precisely and so there's no heroism
in it
and yeah there's no call it to well
because and because finally i call it
the culture of self-invention is a very
boring culture
stanley howard was a methodist
theologian who said he defined
liberalism or you know the modern
attitude as i have no story except the
story i invent for myself
and that's finally a very boring place
to live it seems to me that
in fact you're part of this incredibly
rich and complex
narrative which i would refer to as
god's creation and god's providential
movement but i go back to luke's gospel
you know when jesus says to them
duke and ultim is at the latin go out
into the depths
you people have been horsing around in
the shallows way too long that's where
the fish are by the way
but also it's where adventure is it's
where that was where the
glory of life is get out into the depth
and we have i think allowed our people
to be kind of horsing around by the
seashore all the time
it's also shallow it's also where what
protects you from hell is
because you you need to be engaged in
something that's
deeply meaningful enough to justify the
suffering
and and and so you know part of what
happens in the story of christ is the
only thing deep enough to justify that
level of suffering
is absolute immersion in a cosmic drama
and then you ask yourself well are we
each are we each emerged
immersed in a cosmic drama and it's aw
it's not so easy to say no to that
it's a life or death situation and
everything's in it
well and i would say the the instinct of
a christian is to go where the suffering
is
so i spent a lot of my life forming
priests so working in the seminary
eventually i was the rector of the
seminary
so my job was to help these young guys
discern the priesthood
and i would say that's that's the the
test
i mean do you do you have an instinct to
go where the pain is to go where the
suffering is
if you want to live a comfortable life
then don't become a priest you might be
a bad priest
you know if you embrace a comfortable
life but it's the mother teresa model
it's the duke and ultim go out into the
depths
and the depths mean the depth of human
suffering
with what you guys are doing why isn't
it working well what's
what's our problem it's true that we're
not doing enough of that and i do think
we've succumbed a bit to the modern
thing which is a preoccupation with
rights and freedom and my individuality
and so on
but you see this with church activism so
much now is that
so much so like the church seems to be
replacing itself in some sense with
social activism it's like we've got
enough social activists
yes well but i'd say this pope benedict
xvi was a great
intellectual hero of mine said the
church always does three essential
things
the church worships god it evangelizes
and it cares for the poor poor broadly
construed as i say anyone who's
suffering right
but that first move as we said earlier
is indispensable the church worships god
it teaches the world right praise
because without right praise the whole
thing falls apart
secondly it evangelizes what's that well
that's a cool thing too because
uwangelion in greek
good news they were playing with that
because the
the romans would have used that in the
eastern part of the empire
to announce an imperial victory they
would send an evangelist ahead
with the good news um hey caesar won a
victory
so these very edgy first christians who
had zero social status no power no
military behind them said oh no no i got
the true ewan guelion
it's about jesus risen from the dead who
was put to death by caesar
but whom god raised so that's the
proclamation of the good news that now
we have hope now
the sacrifice has been made and god's
love is greater than anything that's in
the world
okay now i got those two things in place
now serve the poor
now go where the pain is go where the
suffering is but if you divorce them
from each other and that
that has happened so who cares about
worship and that's fussing around with
altars and sacristies and
who cares about evangelization let's
just get down and serve the poor
then it does devolve simply into social
work right
but if the three are together worship
god
evangelize the dying and rising of jesus
and serve the poor
now the church is is cooking you know
all right so let's let's look at the
second one of those so
yeah you know it seems to me i i can
understand
this not that whether i can understand
it or not is a hallmark of its validity
but i
have to try to understand what i can
understand i can understand the idea
that
bearing forward in a moral direction
acting
as if being is intrinsically good and
that hum that humanity as part of that
is also intrinsically good
bearing up under bearing all that up as
a set of propositions
even in the most extreme cases of
suffering
i can see that as a valid moral good
that's
that's christ's refusal to be um
what would you say corrupted by the
injustice of his
and and terror of his fate
and so that might be something like you
don't have the right to become
a tyrant no matter how badly you were
tyrannized let's say
yeah and i think that's an unshakable
moral proposition
um but then there's the resurrection
element of it because i could say
well the first thing i would say is well
i kind of understand that
psychologically
parts of us die and and they have to die
because they're in error they have to be
cast off and
we're reborn constantly as a consequence
of our
movement our ascent forward there's no
movement forward without some death of
the past
and so i can see the resurrection idea
as a
metaphor for the part of us that
continues onward despite
our failures and constantly
reconstitutes our spirit
it's not something trivial but then
there's the insistence on
in the church of the bodily resurrection
which is
well let's call that a stumbling block
to modern belief
no no doubt about that that's something
more than mere metaphor
and so you might ask well why is it
insisted upon
why isn't the proposition that
you you have a transcendent moral
obligation to bear
to to to operate for the good of all
things regardless of your suffering
a hard line no justification with
um the defeat of death necessitated i'm
not trying to make a fundamental
critique of the idea of the resurrection
because i know there are things that i
don't know i
i know that for sure and god only knows
how the world is fundamentally
structured but
but it seems and this is a nietzschean
criticism in some sense tuna freudian
criticism it's
that seems in in some real sense too
good to be true
yeah so and and so what do you make of
the
what do you make of the resurrection how
do you conceptualize it
even as it's related in the gospels
yeah good you're raising a lot of
interesting things first of all
everything you said about it
in terms of psychological um archetypes
and metaphors
good fine i think those are legitimate i
think those are
our correct perceptions of things and it
has indeed functioned that way in a lot
of the literature of the world
resurrection type stories but i think
what's really interesting about the new
testament
as as lewis said you know c.s lewis when
someone said well
the new testament is just another
iteration of the ancient myth and he
said
anyone that says that has not read many
myths because
there's something so distinctive about
the new testament and what i
i would say jordan first this
i think from the first page of matthew
through revelation
what you get throughout is this what i
call this grab you by the shoulders
quality
they knew about literature that is
conveying deep psychological
and and philosophical truth you know
paul certainly knew that literature very
well
um it doesn't sound like that though it
has overtones with it
it bears some of that it has family
resemblances with it
but what what you find on every page
is this one galleon this good
news so everything you said is true i
think it is true
but it's not exactly news it's part of
the philosophy of perennis that's been
around for a long time and a lot of the
great thinkers of the world
and again i agree with it i like the
philosophy apprentice
but the new testament is people
who grabbed everyone they met by the
shoulders to say
something happened something's happened
here that we were not expecting
that was not part of our of our thought
system
and it's so shaken us up that we feel
obligated to go
careering around the world and indeed to
our
deaths announcing it and defending it
and what it was was the fact
here in the in the 10th chapter of acts
of the apostles uh
this sort of almost tossed offline we
who ate and
drank with him after his resurrection
from the dead
um i don't think people trading in
mythic talk
use that kind of language mythic
language again i say it with high praise
i love the myths
but you know once upon a time and or in
a galaxy far far away
and then a mythic story unfolds but you
read the acts of the apostles
do you hear about what happened it was
versus up in galilee and then in judea
you know those people that john the bat
remember john the baptist well and then
this jesus and then in jerusalem and
then
we who ate and drank with him after his
resurrection from the dead
it's that's what and then look at paul
paul who saw him
on the road to damascus now the paul
line letters
man they do not read like myths they
just don't
and i love the myths i love the
philosophy apprentice but it doesn't
read like that it reads like someone
who is has been so bowled over by
something and he wants you
to know about it and it's changed
everything
and i think what it was was what we said
earlier it's
okay now now we know god's mercy
and love is greater than anything we can
possibly do why because we killed god
and that's why paul will say i'm going
to hold up one thing to you christ and
him crucified
and crucified and it was the most
horrific thing they could imagine in the
ancient world
it was deeply embarrassing even to talk
about a crucifixion
paul says no no let me put it right in
your face see
the author of life came and we killed
him but i got the good news who won
gilean
is god's mercy and love is is greater
because he brought this jesus back from
the dead well you do have a you do have
the following argument which is that it
isn't clear which is harder to believe
whether that happened or whether people
made it up
because if they made it up that was
really something and that that does
strike me quite frequently reading the
new testament there are there are lines
in there that hit
so hard you think hmm it isn't obvious
to me how someone could have just
thought that
up so and there is that well and young
carl jung
who i greatly admire you know he
believed i think in the same way that
c.s lewis did that
and he doesn't talk about this that much
but that there is this archetypal
mythological pattern of the dying and
resurrecting hero that has this
psychological reality which is
extraordinarily deep
yeah but that that archetype was
realized once in history
and that's the fully realized so it it
it came from the
the mythic realm let's say the realm of
eternal truth
the realm of pattern instinctive pattern
for that matter
and was fully realized at one point in
history and you might think well
if it's going to be fully realized it
has to start somewhere
you know it can't start everywhere at
the same time or right
right what does an archetype look like
when it takes flesh
might be a way to get out well well and
and the thing is we
we do see this and it does grip us
because
movies like we see representations of
this all the time
in in my new book i talk a fair bit
about harry potter
and you know harry potter is definitely
an archetype
taking christ's figure taken flesh well
clearly he's in battle with satan
himself
obviously i mean and and she has an
unbelievably profound mythological
imagination and
the thing that's so fascinating about
all of that is that because her
mythological imagination is spot on she
captivated the
entire globe and and produced you know
this immense storehouse of wealth and
dominated the entertainment landscape
for a decade and
you know people don't take that
seriously but it's a it's a great
mystery to watch absolutely they should
it's it's a
it's a phenom you know anything that
grips people's attention like that is
obviously worth paying attention to but
you know
so you know emery lewis called them good
dreams right so all the sort of
archetypal anticipations of the gospel
the good dreams of the race um
or do you think jungian i love young too
but what happens if that archetype of
the person perfectly pleasing to god you
know kant's language
what would happen if that archetype
became flesh and indeed that's how they
put it the word became flesh
and dwelt among them i think that's also
the question we should each be asking
ourselves
in our own lives yeah it's like well who
could we be
and you say well you don't have to ask
yourself that question it's like well
good luck with your conscience then
you should be another christ that's the
objection to the self-created person
it's like
yeah the the idea that you can create
your own values is
well good luck right try good luck with
that project yeah good luck
it's not it's not going to work you know
newman referred to the conscience i
always loved this as the aboriginal
vicar of christ in the soul
so he took the language descriptive of
the pope you know the vicar of christ
but he said the aboriginal vicar of
christ
which is the conscience john henry
newman okay because oh i was thinking of
eric neumann so
no john henry newman and i it's it's a
beautiful way of describing it because
we'd say the christ dwelling within you
is the voice of the conscience
that's calling you to sanctity
ultimately to heroic self-sacrifice to
being who christ is it also is it is
what people worship because
here's a way of thinking about it
technically well look
when i have a conversation with you
there's something i want from you
i want i want everything you can give me
i want you to be as as as as
there as you can possibly be that's what
i'm demanding all the time if my
attention assuming a properly
constituted subjectivity
if my attention wanders that means
you're not delivering
and so if you're wandering around and
everyone's attention is wandering away
from you you're not delivering
and conscience because we're so social
we're
social creatures to the final degree
conscience tells you when you deviate
from the ideal
and that ideal is what people worship
they by attending to that manifestation
of the ideal in you
they worship it and so that's there
it's there in the in the demands that we
can't help but make of each other and of
ourselves
there's no escape from that and so i i
do think it's a perfectly good question
what would happen and this is the right
question for your life
what would happen if you took that
seriously and so
again what i see is that it doesn't seem
to me to be
if the church can no longer attract
young people
it has to be that they're not taking
that
with sufficient seriousness now yeah i
think there's a lot to that i don't want
to externalize the blame it's like i
know the church is a human organization
and all of that and
but but it's still evidence when i was
coming of age so back in like the 1970s
the presumption of the church was we
should make this thing as easy as
possible because if we make it hard
these people are going to run away
so we don't want make it we want to make
it intellectually easy
so i got a very dumb down catholicism it
was through the grace of god that i
discovered later in life the very rich
catholic intellectual tradition
but when i was going through school
including through high school
you know banners and balloons and
collages and it was a very superficial
we got the clearer impression when i was
a kid that english and science and math
and all that were
serious subjects religion was like
religion was like gym or it was like you
know
i don't know what else like art class or
something it was considered not that
serious
so we dumbed it down intellectually and
we lessened the moral demand
for sure because we didn't want i think
people to run away
and then you know i'll say it bluntly
rather pathetically we tried to be as
relevant as possible that was the term
from our time
right and that's like the uncool guy at
the party man
right you know if you have to strive to
be relevant you're you're
you're not you're not on the cutting
edge that's for sure right
and so there's a study i read some years
ago that i thought was very
plausible the conclusion was what young
people find compelling in a
mentor figure are the two things one is
that the person
knows a lot about the subject that he or
she is sharing and secondly
they're really committed to it and when
the kids sense those two things
there's a lot to know here and this guy
or this woman they really they really
believe it
they find that compelling you don't need
you know the the games of relevance you
don't need to dumb it down
in fact smarten it up and and make it as
intellectually challenging
and morally challenging as possible um
we dropped a lot of practices that were
that were much more common years ago
you know to kind of draw young people
into the challenge of it
so that is a problem absolutely well you
know
one of the things that i've been so
delighted by is
my observation that there's a tremendous
hunger for serious conversation
yeah in public hunger for it and when i
when i
have engaged in my lectures i'm always
extending my myself to my limits of
thought
like that's what the lecture is it's an
it's an attempt to go past what i think
and
there's absolutely no doubt that that
um everyone in the audience is on board
with that
i mean it was the case when i debated
sam harris for example that discussion
which
you know was as technically complex as
sam and i could make it and
you know and that might not be as
philosophically complex as the absolute
ideal but it was
it wasn't dumbed down by any stretch of
the imagination and
there there's just there was there's no
reason that that
is if you spoon feed that material
it it catches no one what and i can tell
you this those new uh
atheists so sam and and uh hitchens and
dawkins those guys
uh they were good evangelizers i mean
for their position
uh i deal with yeah and they didn't dumb
it down either they didn't dumb it down
they had the two things i talked about
they were they were intelligent and they
were passionately committed to it
but every day on the internet when i go
into these comm boxes i hear the
phraseologies from hitchens and dawkins
and sam harris
a lot of young people read them they
didn't
hug them into atheism they argued them
into atheism so i've been telling our
people
we got to stop trying to hug people back
into the faith we have to argue them
back in the faith we have to make it
compelling
and i had a worldly challenge i've been
walking with this friend of mine
on talking with him and you know he said
something quite interesting
um he was raised in a communist country
and
was an atheist after that um
he said his family
observed christmas and he criticized
them for that
because it was logically incoherent and
then he realized that all that would
happen if they abandoned christmas was
that they wouldn't have christmas
anymore
it wasn't like he had something to
replace it with right
and so it's magical you might even call
it naive if
if you're of the sort of mind that would
call that naive but
do you want to have it or not and if the
answer is well i'll replace it with
another weekend
then that's really not helpful and the
problem with the atheists is that
they don't have the best they can offer
is something like a materialistic utopia
i've got nothing against that like i've
been talking to people like bjorn
lomberg and
and uh who who who lay out this
vision of an increasingly wealthy
world where absolute poverty is a thing
of the past and where
people can take the levels of health
that are more or less taken for granted
in the west
for granted everywhere in the world
through a process of incremental
economic improvement and
you know more power to that i think yeah
but
i also know that that that isn't
a sufficient story is and there's a kind
of despair that goes along with
material security because the adventure
is drained out of it and dostoevsky
touches on this and this is where i
really learned this when i first
encountered this idea you know
dostoevsky in notes from under the
ground
underground says look
this is something you have to understand
if you gave
people everything they need so that they
had nothing to do but eat cakes and
and busy themselves with the
continuation of the species
if if they were so happy that nothing
but bubbles of bliss would appear on the
surface of the water that they were in
they would smash it all to pieces just
so that something adventurous and unique
could happen and so
like there has to be a call to a higher
order of
spiritual being let's say a
psychological being that accompanies
that materialism or it's
or we won't even kill us no absolutely
it'll kill it'll smother us
um it's got to be the call to sanctity
and the call of sanctity is a call to
love
uh and they're dostoevsky you know love
is harsh and dreadful it's not a cute
little emotion or it's not a
it's not a sentiment real love is harsh
and dreadful because it means going into
the place where people are suffering
and becoming another christ and bearing
the burdens of the world
that's serious business love is is and
something awful about it you know but
when you summon someone there's also
something awful about the judgment
you know because if you love someone you
also hold them to a standard yeah
you will they're good right and that
means holding to a standard
do you know this russia triggers my mind
i'm reading the
these wonderful books by this uh priest
walter chizak i kind of know that name
he died in 1984 but for 23 years he was
a prisoner
in the soviet system so he was arrested
in 1939 right when the war got going
with the
germans and make a long story short he
was in lubianca prison for five years in
moscow
basically in solitary confinement then
he was sent for 15 years or so
to siberia to the worst work camps you
know
and he describes it in this book called
with god in russia
in this kind of bold just
straightforward way
but all through it he says okay i went
into russian to be a missionary to
announce the gospel it's
it's not the way i expected it to be i
didn't expect to be
in a prison camp but okay this is what
god has willed obviously at least his
permissive will is that i be here
so i'll do what i can so for 23 years
this man
set up when he was in solitary a jesuit
program of prayer and he would go
through his day he had the
prayers of the mass memorized then when
he gets to the camps they would smuggle
in little bits of bread and wine so he
would say mass
on a little table clandestinely you know
and he would minister in his own quiet
way
to the people around him i'm telling
that story because
in the most horrific circumstances
in a way he never saw coming he said
okay but i'll try to be a saint here
i'll try to be christ
bear the sufferings of those around me
and bring the grace of god
he was finally sprung in 1963 jfk was
involved in getting him out with a
prisoner exchange
as he left russia he's the plane's
taking off and he
did the sign of the cross over the
country bless the country
and it's an incredibly moving story
because it's not at all flashy it's told
in a really
almost bland manner but it's someone who
decided
no i'm going to go in the depths i'm
going to deal with what i've been given
and it's horrific i'm in a i'm in a
soviet siberian concentration camp doing
hard labor
but i'll be christ for the people here
um
that's it i mean that's the adventure
there's the hero's journey
that he went on so well so let's get
back to the
to the resurrection idea there because
again see that story to some degree
doesn't require the resurrection to
to to to to to underscore his heroism in
fact to say
in some sense to say well that was
motivated by faith in the resurrection
in some sense
undermines the heroism of the action and
again i'm saying i'm not
trying to casually dispense with the
idea of the resurrection
at not least because of its undoubted
metaphorical re
structure and but there is this
this crazy emphasis this crazy idea that
somehow bearing up under all that burden
reformatted the entire structure of
being and that's associated with i
believe
and i'm no theologian i believe that's
associated with the idea of the
harrowing of hell
is that is that well yeah there's
something but i do as a first step
though
that's the church the church
christ's resurrection is the seed from
which the church
grows and the church is the means by
which god wants to reconfigure the world
that's right
we're not there just to kind of whisper
our convictions among ourselves
our whole purpose is to go now and and
recreate the world
that's the church's purpose it reminds
me
i read history and history is so
interesting that it's unbearable right
if you read
history it's it's unbearably interesting
and yet if you go sit in the history
class
taught by the typical history teacher
it's so dull that you can hardly keep
your eyes open and there's
you know you need to memorize what
happened in 1612 and that's not the
point the point is the
unbelievably magnificent drama and so
then again
if that story that that the church is
telling is not
being taken up it's not being sold
there's something about it that's not
being sold properly
i'm not saying you have the answer to
that's true but
like i saw this kid once when i was in
montreal and he was about 17 years old
and he was
big guy big like six foot five guy and
and uh you know like a physical specimen
and he was standing on the corner of of
a
like a shopping area and he had two pink
shopping bags in his hands and he looked
kind of bereft and i thought
you know if you came up to him and said
um
i've got some heroism in battle for you
around the corner
he dropped though and you said it right
he dropped those damn pink shopping bags
in a second and be off for the adventure
of his life
yeah and and you you
it it has to what is it is it a lack of
faith that
a fundamental faith that that is sapping
the lifeblood out of that story because
you're saying well here
i'm calling you to an adventure that's
as great as
any adventure you could possibly
conceive by definition this is the
ultimate adventure that you're being
called
to yeah but but the hobbit hole is so
attractive i mean there's so
billboard would rather stay in his
hobbit hole i mean it's comfortable and
i got my doilies and it's nice it's
comfortable here so
gandolf has to summon him to adventure
it's a it's a
it's a burden it's a task you know and
so the church has got to play that role
of of gandalf to get into these
hobbit holes and get people motivated to
get them out
you know what was it walter cheese like
i'll tell exactly he's a jesuit novice
in pennsylvania
1930-something and
pope pius xi at the time from rome says
russia's just gone communist the church
is being persecuted
i need and he said it this way i need
uh heroes to go into russia and you
jesuits you're kind of my shock troops
i'm going to summon you into russia and
young walter cheesex
18 or 19 says he just knew
that's where i'm going and he went up to
the speaker and said
i'm in okay they sent him to rome to
study russian language and russian
liturgy
and they sent him into russia so i mean
he was summoned he was summoned to
adventure and he took it
you're in why why like what happened in
your life
to to pull you in this direction and and
and and how has it worked
for you you know what was jordan for me
uh i was a catholic kid you know going
to mass on sunday
but not all that interested in religion
and i was interested in
baseball when i was like 13 14. but i'm
in high school
freshman high school class and it was a
catholic high school so it's a religion
class
and one of the teachers laid out for us
one of thomas aquinas's famous arguments
for god's existence
and i did not disbelieve in god and i
believed in god
but i never in my life thought that you
could think about god in a serious way
and it opened up something it set my
mind on fire
and i started going to libraries back in
those days we went to libraries
and i was taking these books of thomas
aquinas off the shelf
i had no idea what i was reading but but
i was i i still
to this day think of those like magical
days that i discovered something that
just turned my
my mind on you know so that was the
opening of the door
then the other book i read at that time
that was so influential was thomas
merton you know merton the
he's a trappist monk he'd been a man of
the world
you know all the way and then had this
huge conversion experience
and becomes the most radical kind of
monk you you can become
and those two thomas's aquinas and
merton
had a big impact on me when i was a kid
because there's something romantic about
it you know mertens was the story of
someone kind of falling in love with god
totally
um that's what got me in the door and
then i followed
a lot of the intellectual path i was
always kind of a thinker type
and that got me into the priesthood and
then you know off i go
but at every stage it was something like
a summoning to
mission is language we would use
summoning to a mission a
ever greater kind of mission that kept
me going
i always found it i don't know the most
compelling option on the table it always
struck me that way is you look at the
options of life like well
serving god yeah duh wouldn't that be
the most exciting
thing is that's it is that apart from
the terror that that might reasonably
evoke it's
it is the best by definition and again
you could just speak psychologically
here
by definition that's the best game you
can play
that's how it struck me when i was a kid
yeah well it's almost a tautology you
know
right it struck me that way you know so
it and i understand everyone's different
everyone's path is different but that's
how it
struck me how grace i would say you know
entered my life
and i truly i've been a priest now for
30 what five years
um bishop now for five years um
i i've i've never been i've never been
unhappy as a priest i mean i've suffered
certainly
and have gone through difficult times
i've never been unhappy though as a
priest i've never been tempted to leave
never felt like oh god why did i do that
i've never felt that
um and this social media enterprise of
yours you know i when i introduced you
i noted that you're perhaps the most
well-known catholic
speaker in social media circles i think
that's a reasonable presupposition
do you have competitors so to speak oh
yeah
there are some people i was one of the
pioneers in a way because
i know like when youtube first got
started was 2006
by early 2007 i did a review of
um scorsese's movie that departed
because my instinct was let's talk about
the culture let's talk about things
going on
that have a religious overtone you know
so i started early 2007
right when youtube got off the ground
and then everything else facebook and
instagram came along
and then others sort of saw what i was
doing and got into the game too but i
guess i was one of the first ones to do
it
not that i know that world that well i
got all these young people that
helped me navigate that world but i've
been providing a lot of the content
and and so what's what's that been like
and how is that received by your peers
or your superiors for that matter i i
would say
well to answer the second part first i
think well i think they saw oh yeah this
is good i'm glad he's doing it i'm glad
someone has taken the initiative
and they began asking me early on like
hey tell us more about this and how are
you doing it and what are the pitfalls
and how's it working
so i think my superiors have always been
you know very open to it interested in
it
when i've spoken to the now that i'm a
bishop i'll speak at the bishops
conference meetings about it
and there's always tremendous interest
now these are all older men for the most
part they don't know
you know facebook from you know french
fries but
um they get it they get the importance
of it and
and why it's worth doing um and and the
the success of it in a way has been a
source of surprise and delight to me
when i started youtube videos i mean
we thought if we got 300 views we're
doing great i was thrilled when i
my first one got the 300 views um
you know and then it just grew it just
grew from there and i think it was a
willingness to
talk about the culture and then engage
people
so i can't do it as much now but in the
early days i would get in the comm boxes
and i would really
enter into these debates and you know as
you know 97
of people that come on com boxes are mad
at you for some reason or they
you know don't like what you're saying
so okay i was able then to at least have
an argument i could get into the you
know
lists with them well it's interesting
you know you say that because
i've certainly met my fair share of
opposition
in the media domain let's say especially
with
you know the legacy media um but
i'm stunned by the positivity of the
comments
it's absolutely overwhelming i can't
really make
heads or tales of it that it's so
consistent and it's been very sustaining
to me
so and i i don't really i don't
i guess the reason i think that's the
case is because
i think i'm encouraging people you know
who haven't had any encouragement or
enough and that's lots of people maybe
everyone
because i mean how much people should be
encouraged to the
ultimate degree right they should say
well you
want to reveal the divine within in your
own particular way
you could do that and you know i'm
curious about
you did the reddit ama didn't you a
couple times
well i did that i've done it twice now
and i think one
one year i was like you were first and i
was
third and not because they knew me i'm
sure they didn't
but i just got on and said i'm a
catholic bishop who loves to dialogue
with
non-believers and atheists or something
right so you were asking
also inviting some push back there as
well so yeah but but it was
i loved it we got an enormous response
now a fair amount of
obscenity and just people that hate
religion see part of it might be
religion that i'm so
institutionally identified with religion
so all that
but but i loved both times i did that
the the questions that emerged and the
themes that emerged
were very illuminating to me you know so
no i i've i've loved that world too of
entering into it and it's you know it
certainly gets attention people watch
these videos and
then i've done a lot of you know writing
and so on longer form things i've done
documentary films as well
so what kind of crowd are you getting
now with your youtube channel and your
podcast what what's your audience
numbers
yeah we have like 77 million or
something
uh you know total views uh oh yeah
on you on your channel yeah wow that's
that's
that's a lot are people cutting up your
your videos and posting them
in pieces as well yeah sometimes
sometimes
um i'm trying to get the an average it
depends on the type of video we're doing
but yeah we're getting you know good
numbers solid numbers
um not in your ballpark but uh well 77
million total views is
like that's far beyond respectable
that's
i mean you know you think about
comparing that to something like a
published book
i mean youtube has a reach that's
absolutely
staggering right and i appreciate that
very much you know that all these
different forms and then that's just
youtube you know many of all the other
forms of social media so you know i'm
look as an evangelist as someone trying
to speak for the church i'm delighted by
that
and um you know we just did it we just
as as you did i mean
i think the first video of yours i saw
you were in a
like a poorly lit room sitting in this
chair talking about nietzsche or
something i thought
wow this guy someone said oh he's
getting these enormous numbers and i
thought well
but it speaks to the wasn't the
production quality that was doing it
yeah no it wasn't it was it was the it
was the content and the willingness to
talk about important ideas and to do it
in a way that respects the audience i
think all that
uh is is worthwhile you know
well look that was that was really good
um
we got we got nice and deep into it that
yeah i
appreciate that very much um loved it i
wish it
i wish it could have gone on longer i
had more questions but
i think i've i've exhausted my capacity
for
for concentration we went for a couple
hours huh yes well it's a good natural
end i would say as well
yeah no i loved it jordan thank you i
appreciate you taking the time you know
anything else that that you
um want to say or that we didn't cover
just you know tell your wife's name is
tammy right yes tell her you know we did
just came out with it it's on youtube a
series of reflections i did on the
rosary
and i know with her interest in the
rosary that she just go on youtube
and check it out she might find that
interesting yeah it's too bad we didn't
have a chance to talk to that a little
about that because yeah just tell her
that because i i love the rosary too
it's a great prayer and
it it works at so many different levels
you can look at it psychologically and
even physically you know what that does
to you so have a look at those maybe and
uh you know give her my best and
i remember we were in rome
right after you and i spoke the first
time our team was in rome doing some
filming
and i think we i forget whom we sent it
to somebody in your office but we did a
little video
and i knew that your wife was very sick
at the time i didn't know that you were
on the verge of your
issues you know but i just said we said
mass in my room there in
in rome which is the hotel room and said
it for your wife so we sent that to you
so let her know that we have been for a
long time praying for the two of you
well that's much appreciated and
certainly all the care that people have
shown
including the care that you've shown has
been extraordinarily helpful
and she's listening to you on a regular
basis
and she's certainly found the practice
of the rosa tammy is quite a physical
person
and yeah so she's it's practice for her
rather than
an intellectual endeavor not that she's
incapable of intellectual endeavor but
she's an adept practitioner so she's she
does
as well yoga for years in your hand
matters you know it's a very physical
thing yes well it was it was
it was it was it didn't it helped her
maintain peace while she was
facing death yeah essentially
continually and
and so the the the that's the ritual
element which we never talked about at
all
partly i suppose because you know we
tend towards the abstract in the
intellectual but
the ritual next time the ritual
shouldn't be yes exactly the ritual
shouldn't be uh
dismissed no i'm a catholic heck
ritual's our whole thing you know
yeah well there's peace in ritual right
that's the thing you know what to expect
it's a place of safety and and and in a
world that changes constantly
ritual is the only thing that provides
order and so
we may need that now more than ever
because things are changing so
unbelievably fast which is also partly
why the church should be careful about
being too relevant it's like yep i
agree i agree yeah all right well thank
you very much
no i enjoyed it immensely and god bless
you me too um thank you
i need all the blessing from god i can
get i can tell you that
so i'll keep praying for you thank you
very much
[Music]
you